good morning Hank it's Tuesday so this
is the story of how our educational
Media Company complexly came to sponsor
a worldclass athlete specifically a
Tetris player in Oklahoma okay so this
is video of me playing Tetris a game
where the goal is to make complete lines
of blocks I've been playing this game
since it came out 34 years ago for the
Nintendo Entertainment System and I'm
pretty good like I start at level 9
speed which you're seeing here if you
get over 100,000 points before d your
end screen is a cool space shuttle
taking off next to the Kremlin a
reference to the game Soviet programmers
and if you get over 120,000 points you
get the best end screen of them all the
Kremlin taking off while a UFO is on the
Launchpad I can usually reach the
highest end screen in the game a couple
times I've even gotten over 300,000
points this is 13-year-old Willis Gibson
also known as blue scooty playing Tetris
Willis usually starts at level 18 or 19
and then keeps playing long after mere
mortals like myself would die he can
even play after the so-called kill
screen of level 29 where the pieces
start moving so fast that most of us
can't even move them to the left or
right Willis uses a special controller
technique called rolling to move the
pieces super fast and he is ludicrously
wondrously Stupify andly good at Tetris
I in 34 years have gotten over 300,000
points I don't know maybe 30 times
Willis's top score is over 6 million the
defining feature of Tetris has always
been that you don't beat it Hank you
made a song about this many many years
ago called the man who throws the tetris
piece all about how you cannot beat the
god behind Tetris because he will just
keep throwing pieces at you faster and
faster until eventually you cannot go on
indeed each of the billions of Tetris
games played over the last three and a
half decades have ended the same way the
player loses until that is a few weeks
ago when Willis became the first person
ever to play Tetris until the game
crashed freezing not at level 9 or level
29 but at
level
157 at which point he had been playing
Tetris at this speed for something like
minutes oh my
God oh my God oh my God
yes oh my God oh my
God this clip made national news Willis
became known as the person who beat
Tetris who finally defeated the man who
throws the tetris piece by causing the
game's code
to break in the face of his
extraordinary
Brilliance and that Hank is when you
called me and said do you know this kid
who beat Tetris and I said yes of course
I did in fact I was watching live when
it happened because I am a massive fan
of classic Tetris and then you said
should complexly sponsor him and I said
yeah so I reached out to Willis's mom
who's a high school math teacher and
asked her what she thought of the idea
and she loved it as did Willis who
watches some of our stuff now and again
and that is how we came to be the lead
sponsors of Willis's twitch and YouTube
live streams with complex Le's beautiful
logo prominently featured I don't want
to brag Hank but I believe that
complexly which makes crash course and
saow and eons and much more is now the
first ever online media company to
sponsor a worldclass Tetris player now
lest you worry that your patreon dollars
are going to support this lovely
silliness I want to be clear that Hank
and I are paying for this sponsorship
out of our pockets but while Willis's
live streaming does not reach billions
of viewers or whatever I do think it's
kind of a good investment the brands
within complexly crash course and saow
and study hall and eons and so on are
really strong but far fewer people know
about complexly itself the company that
makes all that stuff and we've been
looking for ways to increase awareness
of the overall company we think it's
important to get the word out not just
about what we make but about who we are
and we are complexly a production
company that now employs over 70 people
who work on a huge variety of
educational content so through this
sponsorship we get to do that while also
encouraging and supporting an
extraordinary young person also Willis
is kind of like a NASCAR driver when it
comes to thanking his sponsors on stream
which we appreciate yeah thank you thank
you comp
no thank you Willis and thank you Hank
for the idea of sponsoring Tetris
players sometimes your ideas Hank they
are just ludicrous and terrible and
sometimes they are ludicrous and awesome
I will see you on Friday